so the idea of this talk started a long
time ago in 2011 I used to give this
talk called css3 secrets because CSS li
was a thing back then you now know that
there's no such thing as css3 but back
then it was the buzzword and it had ten
three ten things you may not know about
CSS like ten tips apart from them all
being CSS tips they had nothing else in
common it was just cool stuff that I
wanted to share about CSS and then I did
a sequel more CSS secrets the next year
and then for the next five years I was
doing more specific talks talks about
color talks about border-radius
talks about CSS variables and I've
always wanted to do a third sequel well
a second sequel of this series and today
I'm I'm presenting this third second
sequel for the first time and I hope you
like it so let's start with the first
one you might have noticed in the cover
of this of this talk this cut out text
effect and I'm gonna show you how to
actually do this effect with the least
amount of CSS so here is a starting
point
I have a black heading with a white
color and the black background obviously
this is this won't include like all the
code used for this because I don't need
to show you how like the background
image showing these two ladies is
applied or anything I'm just going to
show you the relevant parts of this so
how many of you have heard of blending
modes about 1/2 or 1/3 I would say so
blending modes allow us to control how
the current element blends with whatever
is behind it and specifically here the
multiply blend mode is very useful
because as you will see once I apply it
I actually get the cut out text effect
but notice that if I didn't have a black
background here if I had say my favorite
pink
that wouldn't quite work I would get a
different effect it might be a nice
effect I would I might want that effect
but it's not a cut out text effect this
only works with black and I'm gonna show
you a different technique for white and
I have not found a solution for any
other color so but why does this work
because if it's if I just tell you like
this this one line and it works and and
if you use it you get this effect what's
the point it's just one more thing to
memorize so I made this little
application which lets you specify two
colors and you can play with it after
that after the talk because my slides
are online so you can input like to CSS
colors here any color work even like
named colors and you select a blending
mode and you see both the result of
their their combination and the math
used to produce it so these blending
modes come from Photoshop you might have
used these they have exactly the same
name in Photoshop and it was Adobe that
originally proposed them to the working
group a few years ago so why does this
effect work because basically multiply
just means what it what the word says it
multiplies the RGB components of each
color notice here that the color in the
middle is produced by just multiplying
the red components and the green
components and the blue components and
this is the color we get this this
column here so what happens then if the
color in the foreground is white which
is 100% everything you can see that
basically if you multiply anything by
100% what do you get back you get this
thing you multiplied right so any color
you multiply with white you just get
that color which is why our white text
see we had this white text here and that
white text now became transparent
basically cut out because it got
combined with the background and
combining white with whatever gives us
whatever similarly why did the black
stay black because if we input black
here notice that if we multiply
something with zero what does it give us
it gives us zero right so if we multiply
black we get black in general multiply
always gives us a color that is at least
as dark as that as the darkest of the
two colors so this is why this works and
gives us black for black and cut out for
white so what do we do the opposite
effect when we have a white background
and we won't cut out text there multiply
won't work because of what I mentioned
the white becomes transparent and the
black becomes black so the screen
blending mode comes to save us here
which gives us exactly what we want and
we can reason about it in the same way
if I select screen here the math is a
little more complicated I'll give you a
few seconds to process it
so notice remember this is the result we
have black becomes cut out and white
stays white so let me show you the white
first
so with white this component becomes
zero and it's zero for all three of them
so this is getting multiplied by zero so
we have 100% for each of those three
components which gives us white and that
is why white stays white for black this
component becomes 100% so it's useless
it's just like multiplying by one and
then this gives us 100% minus 100% and
this become because we have two minuses
it becomes a plus so it gives us 80% and
same for the other two components
so basically when we screen with black
we get whatever color we had behind
which is why it gives us the cutout text
effect so if you haven't heard about
blending modes before I know many of you
might be wondering okay this is cool
yeah but what about browser support
browser support is pretty decent
actually 86% of users and remember if
blending modes are not supported you
actually pretty get a pretty decent
fallback this is the fallback it's still
perfectly readable you don't even need
to do any other supports or anything so
the takeaway from this first secret is
that with multiply blending mode black
it becomes cut out and white is opaque
and with a screen blending mode why this
cut out
and black is opaque and there are many
interesting things to observe with other
colors so I suggest you play with the
app a little bit afterwards and if you
discover something cool let me know so
the second secret is using characters as
images look at the background of this
slide it's actually using emojis and
characters for the number two it's not
images so how does that work so we're
using in this example I'm using a data
URI with an SVG and contrary to what
they've told you
what you've been told you don't actually
have to URL escape everything you only
have to URL escape very few characters
URLs actually have very few reserved
characters and everything else just
works today and also for CSS when you
have a multi-line string you have to
escape the line breaks which is why
every line ends with a slash
yes it's very annoying and chances are
during this example I'll probably forget
it at some point but you have to
remember there's a slash at the end of
every line otherwise hell breaks loose
so here I have a circle and I can make
the background a bit smaller and now I
have many circles but a circles not very
interesting right I could do this with a
radial gradient if I wanted what is more
interesting is the text element so SVG
supports a text element for putting text
in our image you can't see anything
right now because by default the
baseline is 0 which makes which means
that the letter is outside my image but
now that I've given it a baseline of 1m
you can actually start seeing something
and let me make it a bit bigger so I
have a view box of 100 by 100 here and
I've made it again I've given it a font
size of 100 so I get a pretty big A and
that could mean I could I could use like
I could put any characters here or even
better I could put emojis here and you
know what's even better because it's
just SVG and SVG supports anything
almost anything that you're used to you
may see where this is going except I
have to escape this I think it's % 7
what is the brace yeahit's % 7b and I'm
gonna use a % 7b here there is our
unicorn again and I'm gonna apply a
transform a rotate transform and here
I'm gonna give it a style attribute with
an animation of foo one second infinite
alternate and maybe let's make it - so
you can see here that not only you can
use this technique to have images but
they could also be animated images who
needs animated gifs and a P and G and
all that you could have SVG which is
much more awesome and you can actually
use this to style meter elements to look
like rating widgets here this is just a
meter element if I change it I can get
like all kinds of numbers and it's just
using this technique to style it it's
just using two stars as width as images
with this technique this star is faded
out and this star is not and yes I'm
using this WebKit pseudo element here
but there is an equivalent one for each
browser if you if you look it up there
is a pseudo element for Firefox and
there's a pseudo element for edge and I
hope eventually we standardize this
because I'm just as fed up about this as
you are but right now we have to use
this proprietary pseudo elements if we
want to style meters but the thing is
now that we've done that we could turn
this into a chocolate ice-cream meter
isn't that awesome
[Applause]
so the takeaways here is that you can
turn glyphs into animated images with
SVG data your eyes you should escape
some characters but not everything like
we like people used to think we had to
do and you can use this trick to even
style meters with discrete icons but the
wonders of SVG data your eyes don't stop
here so the next secret is also about
it's also related to SVG try to think
how you could do this border with CSS we
can't do it with CSS without SVG but we
can do a lot of cool things with SVG so
it's worth looking more into it so here
I have a simple rectangle it has a
stroke a stroke with the four pixels and
there is a property called stroke -
array which lets us have strokes with
custom lengths of dashes and custom
lengths of gaps and there is also a
stroke - offset property that lets us
move where these dashes start from so
look at what's happening as I'm reducing
this it's animating and you know what's
even better you can animate this with a
keyframe animation so let's do that
let's add a style element with a
keyframes row that will call marching
ants and it will make the dash offset
not minus 94 but all we need to do is
all we need is minus 15y minus 15
because the dash length is 10 and the
gap is 5 so 15 will get us exactly where
we started so if we continue this and if
I
animate infinitely will get the marching
ants effect so let's apply the animation
marching ants with marching ants let's
say one second infinite so you see that
it sort of moves can you can you see
what's happening in the back so you see
that it sort of moves but it's not like
what you would expect it's it's it's as
if it's getting tired at some point and
then it picks up again the reason is
that by default the timing function of
animations is ease but we can add linear
to make it linear and now it's the
proper marching ants effect that we know
we can make it a bit faster because
that's a bit slow yeah I like this
better so we can use it for like a
selection or something but right now
this is just an SVG so what we wanted
was to apply it to an HTML element as a
border so I'm gonna copy this here and
here I have a div it's just a div with a
class of unicorn and look at my awesome
border as a content and here I have the
SVG data URI ready but I'll need to add
some slashes and another slash and
another slash and there it is and it's
fully flexible if I go here because I've
given it content editable so I can
change it if I go here and change it it
just adapts it's just like a normal
border except it's cooler
[Applause]
thank you so what else what other cool
thing we can do with SVG so here I have
a simple rectangle with a 40 pixel blue
stroke that's not very cool we can do
that with CSS normal CSS as well but you
know what else what we can do with SVG
that we can't do with CSS gradient
strokes so gradients in SVG are a little
more awkward because they came way
before way way before CSS gradients so
they have a completely different syntax
which you can see here but it's a it's a
little more verbose but it basically
does the same things let's make it 0 AC
yep this blue and now you well you can't
see it because I haven't applied it
anywhere yet so let's go here where it
sets the stroke to a color oh and I need
to give my gradient an ID and here I
just say URL hash whoa and now I have a
gradient stroke and I can also apply a
gradient transform to make it a diagonal
stroke and yes everything is different
in SVG like the way we specify angles
even the way we specify transforms
notice that there is no degrees here and
if we try to specify the transform the
same way as in CSS it doesn't work
anymore
so it's not ideal but at least it lets
us do a lot of really cool things so now
like the previous time we just have a
rectangle here how do we turn it into a
cool CSS border on an HTML element same
way I will copy it here again we have a
div with a class of unicorn and I'm
gonna go here and paste it in add some
slashes and there we are
notice that because this is basically a
background image
we don't get any offset like the the
text is still overlapping our border but
we can do that easily with like with
padding and then it works just fine
notice that even though my stroke width
is 40 pixels my padding is is 20 why is
that the reason is that the stroke I
actually end up seeing is only half the
stroke the other half is on the outside
yes it's very weird it will become more
clear if I'm turn this into dashes just
like before I'm gonna do this and then
now you still don't see it but if I
apply line cap round well and make my
gaps a bit bigger now you start seeing
what's seeing what's going on here I
can't really use round line cups because
half of my stroke is on the outside and
what's even worse there is no way to fix
this there is no easy way to fix this
because we can't really say calc
in the width and height we can't say
100% minus 20 pixels cuz like most
browsers don't support that and there is
a property that is supposed to control
this
I think it's called stroke offset or
offset stroke or something but no
browser supports it so if you like these
things start pushing browsers a bit to
implement more of the cool SVG features
because they think we don't care
seriously that is why browsers are not
implementing cool new stuff in SVG
there's a ton of stuff that is planned
for SVG in browsers are just not
implementing it because they think that
developers don't care about SVG so show
them that they're wrong tweet about it
tweet about SVG and how great it is so
the takeaways from this is that SVG's
with no view box notice that I didn't
specify any width or height or view box
for these SVG's they spread to cover the
entire area and but strokes don't
straight
they say this they say the same widths
we specified which is exactly what we
want for four borders like this so the
fourth secret is about creating headings
with a flexible line around them that
just adjusts to that just adjusts to the
heading content you don't have to
animate them like they are over here
that I just thought that was cool but in
a real website please don't animate them
they will be just as annoying as a
marquee tag so here we have a heading
the only reason I've added content
editable is so that I change its content
afterwards and show you that it's really
flexible and here we have before and
then after pseudo elements which is the
key for this so the main idea is that
I'm gonna add some before and after
pseudo elements here I'm actually gonna
give them a content for now but I'm
gonna remove that afterwards this is
just to show them to show you what's
happening and similarly I'm gonna give
this a background of yellow just to show
you what's happening but we're gonna
remove this afterwards so the idea is
that these pseudo elements are gonna
become our flexible lines by using the
wonders of flexbox
so right now we don't see much of a
change by applying flex because there's
nothing to flex really so let's give the
heading a width of 100% and let's make
the pseudo elements flexible by using
the Flex shorthand so now this is
already starting to get there right so
let's remove these horrible colors and
let's remove the a because we don't need
it
so now we're sort of getting there
already you can see it here it's already
nice and flexible but it doesn't look
very pretty so what should we do let's
reduce the height a bit and now let's
make it centered this is already getting
there
let's make it thinner and let's give it
a bit of margin and there we go that's
already one version of this effect
however we could do other cool things as
well I mean as you've seen in the cover
of this we could also give it a
background and give it's thin and have
stripes there another thing we could do
is instead of having a background we
could have a border with the border
width of the top and bottom being point
one and then left and right being zero
and actually this is a bit too thick
still maybe something like this and
maybe we could give it a gray color as
well so as you can see the possibilities
are infinite but what happens when the
hitting becomes so big that there is no
space anymore well as you can see we
don't get the lines anymore which kind
of makes sense so flexbox just takes
care of that without us having to do
anything for when the text is too big so
the takeaway from the fourth secret is
the text nodes and pseudo elements can
be flex children and also grid grid
items if you're using grid we're going
to use that later on so the fifth secret
is about having accessible CSS pop-up
menus I'm sure you've seen this many
times how many of you have done a pop-up
menu like this with just CSS at some
point in your life most of you right
it's like one of the exercises that
people do when they're learning CSS so
the problem with these menus is that
they don't really work with the keyboard
so unlike what the skating is showing
the reality is more like this so here I
have a nested list which have styled to
look like a menu again the exact styling
doesn't really matter so we're not going
to look at it the only part we're gonna
look at is the part that shows and hides
the menu because that that is more
relevant the thing I want you to
remember is that each menu item is an a
element and then there is a ul for the
submenu with list items that also
contain a
so if I click here I focus on the
project's menu and if I have it open I
can actually tab through the sub menu
items but that's not how it usually
works for keyboard users they don't like
hover on the icon the on the menu first
and then use the keyboard what really
happens is that they focus on the first
item and then they press tab and nothing
happens in the sub menu they don't even
know there is a sub menu it just goes to
the second item and the third item so
how can we fix that one possible
solution would be to open the sub menu
when the a item is focused so we can use
the a focus pseudo-class and say a ul
that is after a focused link should be
displayed so now if projects is focused
with the keyboard the sub menu does open
and now we can see that there's a sub
menu there but what happens when we try
to tab through it disappears it's not
actually usable it's just teasing us
like here there's a sub menu but we you
can't use it unless you use your mouse
which is why until now using CSS to do
these kinds of sub menus was actually an
anti-pattern unless you also use
JavaScript but now we got a new pseudo
class called focus within that doesn't
just match the focused element itself
but also all its ancestors so how can we
use this to our advantage here so we're
gonna say the item it has focus within
it then can you still hear me there's
weird stuff happening with the
microphone okay so if the LI item has
focus within it then the UL inside it
should that it should display so you can
see that now if I tab through it
actually works
and similarly I can tap the blog tab tab
tab it works just fine like I like it
it works like those menus that have
JavaScript except without the JavaScript
so focus within is fantastic for
accessibility and pop-up menus is just
one example you might wonder what is the
browser support for focus within and it
looks like I forgot to add a slide on
that but we can go - can I use quickly
and you can see that it's actually
pretty decent it's only edge that's
holding us back and it has like 0.02
percent market share so and 1.67 percent
here you can always include like a
fallback or a polyfill for the four edge
so also in the future we might also get
target within so that all these all
these websites that use the target
pseudo class to the to open or close
certain items now with target within we
would be able to display something when
we don't have a hash and the URL its
target with and would also be super
useful I can't wait to see it but it's
not there yet it no browser has
implemented target within yet so the
sixth one is about variable funds for
non variable strokes what does that mean
it sounds very cryptic I'm gonna show
you what it means here so but before I
do how many of you have heard of
variable funds that few come on if you
fear the variable funds raise your hand
okay well the rest of you are in for a
huge surprise so remember how in the
beginning of computers our phones were
not actually vector based but they were
bitmap based and every size had to be
drawn individually
and eventually we got vector phones that
just scaled at any size so variable
phones are an equivalent revolution as
when we got vector phones for the first
time it's like the second big thing that
has ever happened to phones and what
does it mean
so before variable phones each font had
a certain number of waves often just
normal and bold sometimes the stuff
especially the fonts that are used by
graphic designers a lot they also had
like extra light and light and normal
and semi bold and bold and black and all
these weights and they if you wanted to
use those as web fonts you had to
include like seven weights if you
actually wanted all of them and it was
terrible for it was terrible for
performance but it's not just about
performance you could also not make
small adjustments
it was either light or normally nothing
in between
whereas with variable phones we get
everything in between
with just one font and you can see this
is an awesome website for variable fonts
v - fonts com it has a ton of variable
fonts and it's not just weight that that
can change like here you can also see
width changing also the slope and
everything is changing smoothly here you
can you can see the seraphs like this
font becomes goes from serif to -
sans-serif with an different axis like
basically you can have all sorts of
custom axes there is even an emoji font
here with a poop icon with with the hat
of the icon growing and shrinking based
on an axis let me see if I can load this
because this website has the poop
variable fonts as well it's awesome but
I don't know if it will load the Wi-Fi
is a bit slow I'm gonna show you some of
the others while we're waiting for it to
load you can see how like this has
horizontal and vertical proportion here
it's the contrast between the strokes
Changez here it's like the swoosh enos
and something loaded there it is so
notice that if I change the axis there's
a cap height axis accept cap Heights
here it doesn't actually mean upper case
higher it means actual cap height so
yeah variable fonts are super cool and
this secret that I'm gonna show you here
is only about one facet of them so here
I have a heading with multiple lines and
I've adjusted the size of each line the
font size of each line so that it
occupies the entire width but do you
notice something here this looks awful
the the strokes the the widths of the
strokes of each character look
completely different look even though
they all have the same weight the hour
actually appears much bolder than
everything else and the 1st and 4th line
appeared thinner than everything else so
how can we fix it before variable fonts
we did we couldn't really do very much
even if we had a font with like all
weights that we're a thing back then all
we would be able to do would be crude
adjustments like font weight 100 which
is way too thin but so here have
included a variable font called F if met
of VF by monotype it's a free font and
notice that instead of the font weight
descriptor giving us what weight this
font is it gives us a range it has two
values it says this font is between 100
and 900 and you can get all of these
weights from just this one file and same
with font style it says they come it's
from it goes from normal to italic and
by the way font display swap is a cool
new property to look up I'm not going to
show it here because it's kind of hard
to demonstrate and talk but basically it
means load the fallback while the web
font is loading and when the web font
loads then swap it which is much better
than the current behavior of some
browsers
so let's see how variable fonts can help
us here so we can tweak each line
individually so be even though 100 is
too much
maybe 190 is a bit more appropriate and
similarly even though 100 is too much
too little 140 looks more appropriate so
and the fourth one looks okay to me so
I'm not going to adjust it so this is
already useful but what happens if I
change the text there what happens if I
want to change like variable fonts are
awesome and I want to change it to like
variable fonts erm ok ish I guess or
something like then I would have to
painfully adjust the font size and a
font weight again and like every time I
change anything I have to adjust these
separately is there any way to have a
continuous expression that gives us what
font weight we need to specify for each
size so there is a concept in maths
when you have a number of points and you
want to find the curve that matches
these points there's a process called
interpolation that gives you a
polynomial which produces intermediate
values however if you have a lot of
points interpolation can give you a very
high degree polynomial like X to the
seventh for example which in CSS terms
would mean like multiplying something
painfully like seven times because we
don't actually have powers in CSS so we
want something a little simpler we don't
care about the ultimate precision we
just want something that looks okay so
what we can do is there's another math
concept called regression how many of
you have have heard of linear regression
it's usually in the concept of
statistics okay so
linear regression just gives you a line
if you have a number of points linear
regression just gives you a line that
matches these points that there comes as
close as possible to these points
obviously if you have a lot of points it
cannot match all of them exactly if you
only have two points it can match them
exactly so and there's also what is
called quadratic regression which
instead of giving you a line it gives
you a second degree polynomial so this
sounds a little bit abstract but don't
worry about it because we're gonna apply
it in practice so I thought what if we
could use these techniques to derive a
calque expression that will give us the
font white weight for each font size so
that we only have to adjust the font
size so the idea is we would instead of
specifying font size with a property the
Prada font size property we would
specify it with a variable and then I
would say font size for size and then
font weight would be some kind of calc
expression that depends on size but I'm
gonna comment this out right now until
we have the coefficients also because we
want if if in CSS we have MS we cannot
get anything that is not MS we cannot
get numbers from MS so I'm going to
change this to 1.5 and this to 2.8 and
then I'm gonna multiply the size here by
1m so let's look back oh and I'm gonna
set a default size of 1 okay so now
we're back in the original situation so
I've made a linear regression calculator
that piggybacks off of Wolfram Alpha
with you've heard of Wolfram Alpha right
okay so it's like it's a website that
lets you compute a lot of complex math
things so we can input the points we've
discovered so we've seen so far that
when the size is 1 the weight is 300
because we've specified 300 here when
the size is 1.5 the weight is 190 and
when the size is 2.8 the way it is what
was it
140 so 140 and now we see I'll make this
bigger so now Wolfram Alpha gives us a
line that tries to be as close as
possible to all three of these points so
notice that this is not actually very
good
not only it doesn't match any of our
points but it's actually pretty far from
all of them and you can see here when it
says plot of the residuals it goes it
can be off by 40 a foot an increase of
40 in the font weight has a very visible
result so this is actually pretty bad
I'm gonna show you how bad so come on
okay for some reason Wolfram Alpha gives
me an image there and I have two black
copy the image so that it copies the alt
text it's terrible so let's go here and
put that expression in but instead of X
I'm gonna multiply by var size so that
should work and let me comment this out
so we can see the actual effect that we
have actually it's not that bad maybe we
should just leave it at that
well so let's suppose we left it at that
what happens if we change the text
because that's the the real test
otherwise we could have just left the
numbers we had so let's say for example
instead of like four lines we want to
make it three lines so we go here and we
want to change the size wait something's
not right here
oh no okay never mind
so you can see that it's sort of less
good I mean it's it's it still loads
better than what it was before we made
this adjustment but it could be better
so what can we do we can weaken we can
add more points and that way we'll get
we will get a different line but there's
a limit to what you can get with just
the line so another thing we could do be
to find the font wait for like a smaller
number because right now the size of 65
is completely outside the range of
numbers we have we have already put into
that calculation it's not within the
range of numbers we've specified before
it's outside of it so it's even harder
and I'm actually surprised that did so
well I was expecting it to do much worse
in my tests before this talk it did much
worse I'm not sure what I did
differently so we can test like what the
actual the correct font weight would
have been let's say 360 it would have
been like 350 and if we go here and add
another point with 350
it gives us a different line with this
point being completely really really far
from it
so we can select quadratic which gives
us a different curve that fits the
points more closely do notice that if
you remember math at school where you
were where you were graphing
second-degree polynomials you remember
that the shape is not actually like this
it's actually sort of like this so at
some point this expression is going to
be very inaccurate at some point it's
gonna start going out and giving you
completely wrong results so this will
only work for a certain range whereas
the line approach will give you sort of
reasonable numbers throughout so let's
try this I'm gonna actually make this
bigger so you can see what I'm doing
here and I'm gonna try to copy it again
which is torture so you can see the line
here and you can see how far it is and
I'm gonna go back and apply this
expression instead so I'm gonna paste it
here and I'm gonna replace those X's
with my variable and here as well okay
so you can already see that it's sort of
better it's already feeling closer but
the real test is if we have different
sizes so let's try to go through oh yes
yes yes that's why I was like what the
hell yes and you can see now how all the
intermediate sizes sort of make sense we
don't have to specify them all we just
have we just have to find a few points
and calculate that expression and we
didn't even have to calculate it
ourselves and you know what's even
better is that once we find there
oops what did I do here what was it 5:43
once we find the expression we can use
it for other purposes as well so what
other case might in what other case
might this be useful so you know well at
least the more design savvy of you know
that a it's bad to use synthesized
subscripts and superscripts and in the
past font designers had to include
special glyphs for those supers for
those smaller characters because
otherwise this happens
notice that the citation needed
superscript is much thinner than the
rest of the text and same with the
acronym another type of graphic rule is
that acronyms should be smaller like all
caps things should be smaller so that
they're more harmonized with the rest of
the text and they don't stand out too
much but if we do that and the font
doesn't have specially designed small
caps characters then this happens where
the strokes are much thinner but
variable thoughts help us with that as
well and what's even better is that we
don't have to calculate it again we can
just go here and paste the CSS we've
already calculated and then we well we
have to change the size here the font
size the font size the size and change
this but as long as we make that's that
change like we don't have to change
anything else like our expression
doesn't need to be calculated from
scratch it just works and it already
looks much better so the takeaways from
this secret is that with variable fonts
and making small adjustments to fall to
the font weight we can do a ton of
things that before variable fonts
required special glyphs in the font and
special faces in the font and all sorts
of things from the font designer whereas
right now they don't have to put
extra effort in designing the font and I
say no extra effort because they used to
design variable phones before as well
before open typed variable fonts they
the font designers actually designed an
entire range and then had to export it
in individual weights the work for the
variable font was already being done
it's not extra work for the font
designers to create this variation we
just get to enjoy more of their work
their existing work so these kinds of
minor tweaks allow us allow us to
equalize strokes synthesize small caps
superscript subscript sat on of things
and we can use linear or quadratic
regression to avoid calculating the
weight every time for these tweaks it's
not perfect but it can help a lot and
it's definitely much better than just
leaving the weight to whatever it
normally is so the seventh secret has to
do with flexbox and more specifically
responsive flexbox like this header is
showing so can you imagine how to do
this layout with no media queries and
you might be wondering what what's
what's wrong with media queries lis I
like my media queries but sometimes
media queries don't really work very
well because your component might be
used in many different places and it's
size doesn't really depend on the
viewport but on whatever it's inside
like if your same component might be in
many different places and have many
different sizes and yes this is why we
need the element queries but that's a
whole different story we won't get
element queries anytime soon so hacks
like these are kind of the best we can
do right now so let's suppose we have
this sort of forum post type thing or
message comment type thing and let me
show you what happens when I string the
viewport well well or whatever it's
inside in this case it's the viewport
but it could be other things so notice
that this is pretty horrible like it's
pretty much unusable at this point so
what can we do let me walk you through
the HTML first there is a header element
which is the gray area here and there is
a a post element that actually contains
the message and here the parts of the
CSS that are relevant to this is that
the article has display flex and the
post has flex one so that it stretches
to accommodate any remaining space one
thing we can do to help things is to add
flex a wrap wrap and then at least in
small sizes it automatically wraps but
this looks horrible we wanted this to
stretch horizontally so what we can do
is we can add flex to the header as well
whoops and then the vertical layout
works but in in fixing the vertical
layout have broken the horizontal layout
because now this is huge and why is it
huge because the relationship between
these two is basically one-to-one like
it's it I'm basically saying this should
stretch equivalently to fill any
remaining space but I don't really want
that so what I can do is I can give this
a really large number so that when it's
horizontal and they're sharing the same
space we still get the same behavior as
before but when they're vertical whoa
weird things happening here but when
they are vertical
the head there still stretches
horizontally because the default flex is
0 which means flex grow is zero which
means nothing stretches so by giving it
a flex of 1 we say you should stretch to
cover a remaining space but because in
the vertical layout there's nothing out
there it stretches to cover the entire
remaining space you might notice that at
this point this becomes very thin but
the rest of like normal CSS still works
we can give this a min width of say 15
m/s and that way we can control when it
actually switches to a vertical layout
so now it didn't it never becomes too
thin because it just switches to a
vertical layout and all without any
media queries so this is not actually my
trick this was published with the title
flex grow $9.99 hack by someone called
your and Vaughn he if I'm pronouncing
his name right you can follow him on
Twitter over there
so the 8th secret is about all the
flowing grids which again is kind of
cryptic until we see what exactly it's
about so here we have a list of items it
doesn't really matter what items they
are they have classes some of them half
of them have a class of cat and the
other half have a class of human and
also half of them are male and half of
them are female and they're styled
differently the cats have a different
background color the humans have
different emoji so let's assume that I
wanted to display these items as two
columns where the humans were in one
column and the cats were in the other
column how could I do that I could use
display grid and notice that right now
nothing happens because it has one
column by default so I apply grid
template columns
and I say they should both be the same
and a grib gap or say five pixels so
notice that now it's they're
automatically assigned to columns so I
have both cats and humans in both
columns so I want to specify what column
each of them goes so I say human should
go to grid column 1 and then cat should
go to grid call them too but look at
this what happened here so the reason
this happened is that grids are laid out
in rows by default so it laid out the
cats where it should and then the humans
went underneath however we can change
the we can change this layout there is a
grid auto flow property where we can
specify column and this fixes that
problem so now they're properly sorted
just like I wanted and if I wanted the
humans to be in the second column and
the cats to be on the first column that
works too and it's it's completely
independent of the source let's say I
wanted to split them by gender instead
so I would say male in the second column
and female in the first column and that
works too so yeah grid out the flow is a
pretty cool property and it doesn't just
do this another example you can see
another example here with where I have a
list of 10 cats I'm gonna refresh here
because my scrolling is broken for some
reason nope still broken ok I'm gonna
use the scroll bars so I have 10 cats
here throw my free stock for a website
called pixels and I want to display them
in a grid well right now I haven't
specified a template so nothing happens
I can say grid template columns and I
use the repeat function to avoid saying
207 times
or four times so I want them to be in
four columns and four rows of 200 each
and right now it looks really weird
because the images are still their full
size so I can say with 100% and height
100% and then okay this No
oh right typo so notice that I just
committed one of the ten horrible sins
of web design I stretched images but
fear not because object fit comes to the
rescue
and it's supported everywhere oh noes so
this looks kind of like a boring grid so
what I wanted to do is I want to enlarge
some of the cards let's say these but I
might decide otherwise when I see it and
say they spawned two columns all right I
need quotes yes so they span two columns
and two rows so notice that now our grid
looks kind of weird it there's no cuts
here so how can I fix that good Auto
flow to the rescue again so I'm gonna
use the default argA rhythm row but I
can also add a dense key word after it
and now things can be shifted up to
cover any holes in the grid just for the
lulz if I said column this is what the
result is because they're laid out in
columns now I think I prefer row so and
this is the browser support for CSS grid
in case you're not aware of it it's
basically 87 percent of users even edge
supports it so if you were if you were
wondering about that don't CSS grid is
available everywhere so the takeaways
from the secret is the grid Auto flow
defines the direction that what auto
automatic grids are laid out and I say
Auto grids because you could also like
explicit
lycée where everything goes and then
grid ought to flow has no effect but in
most cases you don't want to do that
also the dense keywords prevents holes
in the grid by shifting things up as
necessary and object fit cover prevents
image distortion also object fit contain
and a bunch of other values but cover
makes the image as big as possible and
prevents Distortion
so the ninth secret is about pie charts
I'm sure you've seen linear gradients in
CSS right and you might have seen radial
gradients as well so soon we're getting
a new type of gradient called conic
gradient where the colors go around the
Ray that goes around the midpoint and
the colors are added like the normal
gradient and there is also a Frome
arguments that the that rotates the
gradient so I like this it looks kind of
like a weird shadow and here I have
applied an element a development that
I've called PI and I've given it a
linear gradient which I'm gonna convert
to a conic gradient does that remind you
of anything a hue wheel on color pickers
now we could make that with CSS but we
can make more cool things so if I remove
these colors and then increase this
let's say I make it 40% and then I
decrease this at some point they meet
and then I get a hard line which is a
pie chart and actually notice that this
happens regardless of what as long as
the second numbers big is smaller than
the first it doesn't matter what it is
it could be 0 so I tend to use 0
they're both as a convention to indicate
what should be happening and also so
that it works with whatever value so now
I basically have a pie chart that works
with whatever number I put here and I
could also specify a value CSS variable
that holds the 30% and here I could say
var value
and then I could also specify this in
the style element or via JavaScript this
is why CSS variables are so much
superior over sass variables try going
doing that with sass so I can change it
in the inline style again all via
JavaScript and my pie my pie chart just
adjusts as necessary
it's like almost like a component and
you know what's even cooler okay I'm
gonna take this out of the inline style
now so that we all we have all our code
in one place but what's even cooler is
that the second parameter of var is a
default value and by that by doing that
I could have multiple slices of the pie
let's say I want to add the potential
for a second color so I could do this
let's give it a fixed value now and
let's say black here we have a full
German flag now I don't know why I chose
a German flag so notice that now it
works just fine and actually in your
browsers I can do this it's a new syntax
it's currently only supported by Chrome
so you should have the two consecutive
color stops but this was implemented at
the same time as conic gradients so if
browser supports kkona gradients they
probably support this syntax with the
two positions as well so now I can have
a second variable here with the default
value of zero so that when this variable
is not set I just don't get that color
but I could I could set that color to
something and then I get it just fine
notice that the numbers I specify are
not are not in addition they overlap
like 60% is the total angle of the
yellow not the difference it has from
the first from the red one so that way
could add a tonne of colors let's say
three and four and I could have like
lime and let's say aqua here and they
only appear if I actually set values for
them so I could do value three let's say
80% and basically that way I can have a
pie chart component that shows whatever
percentages I want with however many
slices I want just with a few lines of
CSS yeah I like pie charts too
thank you so another cool thing is let's
say I have just one slice for simplicity
here but everything applies to multiple
multiple slices as well notice that as
I'm changing this it sort of looks like
it's animating which kind of begs the
question would it be cool if I could
actually animate this that way I could
make like a pie chart progress indicator
so I added my keyframes roll and I call
it progress I'm terrible at picking
names for keyframes I hate that we have
to pick a name for everything for every
animation and then let's say to value
100% and then I go here I set this to
zero and I try to add an animation that
sets for progress one second infinite
but look at what happens it just jumps
from zero to a hundred and the reason
for this is that by default CSS
variables are not animatable because the
browser pretends that it doesn't animate
them even though it's obviously
percentage the browser is like yeah I
don't know what you've typed there who
knows you could have typed thread
instead of like 100% I don't know what
you're doing I'll just give up so how
can we fix that the good news is there
is some JavaScript we could write to fix
that to register this property and we
can say this property is the percentage
and we can also say whether it inherits
and what's its initial value is this is
part of a set of new specs called
Houdini which is which is going to give
developers that the power that before
was only for browser engineers and if I
run this snippet and I go back now it
works which i think is really cool I'm
gonna make it even cooler so isn't this
awesome
no chrome is supposed to ship it really
soon
like we've actually cleared it in the
working group even though even though
the spec itself is not ready we've said
that okay this this part of the spec can
be can be shaped like we we had a
meeting we approved it I don't know why
it hasn't shipped yet like I've talked
to the chrome engineer that implemented
it and he told me that it was meant to
ship in April so I'm not sure what it's
holding it up but I expected to ship in
chrome very soon and it says here that
it's in development in Safari as well
and WebKit so hopefully in a few months
that situation will be very different
and these days browsers ought to update
so we don't have to wait years to get it
but this is all this this situation is
also pretty bad even in chrome this is
behind the flag and Chrome the chrome
people are those pushing this so yeah I
guess there are issues to be ironed out
here but I'm very excited about both of
these I can't wait until they actually
make their way in browsers properly and
we can play with them in real websites
so some takeaways from this conic
gradients are coming finally I propose
them five years ago and have been like
putting so much work into them I'm so
glad that it's finally happening
also two colors top positions for bands
of colors and gradients and not just
corny gradients but also all gradients
that's coming to a color stop position
of zero creates hard lines regardless of
the previous position and CSS don't
register property will allow us to
animate custom properties opening up a
lot of cool use cases so the last the
last secret and I'm horribly over time
so the last secret is called descendant
grid items primarily because I could not
think of a better name and this is why
it's not really styled because I it's
really hard to visualize this concept
but let me show you what it's about
this is a very common marker for like
login forms it has two labels username
password by putting the input inside the
label we avoid having to give it an ID
which is always nice because I hate
specifying IDs and let's say we wanted
to use grid layout to display it as a
grid so we apply display grid by default
it takes it puts everything in the same
column which is why they're now under
each other but notice there's no grid so
we say grid template columns and we want
the first column to be author because
that's the side we wanted to adapt to
whatever the label actually is like
username or password we want it to be as
big as that and the second one is
basically whatever remaining space
exists but notice that we got a
completely different result that what we
were hoping for but actually the browser
just did what we told it to do before we
apply the grid on the form the form has
two children it put these two children
in two columns which means the label the
labels are next to each other so how can
we fix that
until recently we couldn't fix that but
there is a new display property called
display contents and called display
contents that basically tells the
browser to not to ignore this element
when it comes to applying CSS like if so
now it ignores the labels when applying
grid layout and also notice that the
labels don't have any styling either so
they're basically completely transparent
as far as CSS is concerned it's like
it's as if the layout is as if the label
element was not there but we still have
our nice semantic HTML our nice
accessible labels but they don't get in
the way of our layout and now we can
have a username and password in the in
the two
puts in grid cells just like we wanted
and if we make this bigger the grid just
adapts and let's give it a nice gap as
well because I don't like this yep
another use case is when you have a
website layout and you want to use
proper markup and like use a header
element for the header but you actually
want elements inside the header to to be
on the main grid of the page as you can
see here like we would want these
elements inside the header to
participate in the overall page grid and
display contents doesn't have amazing
browser support but it's very decent and
it's constantly growing like as you can
see more than one in two users has it
basically two out of three users have it
so the takeaways from the last secret is
that display contents allows us to make
descendants flex or grid children even
though they're descendants and not
actually children and also as I've
mentioned before text nodes are flex and
grid children as well so this is
basically what I've had for today but
before I thank you two things
since we don't have time for questions
because I got hurt I went horribly over
time I'm gonna be in the speaker area
Bruce mentioned where that is I don't
remember it but hopefully I'll find it
I'll be in the speaker area you can come
and ask me questions seriously don't be
shy I like getting questions I like
hearing what you thought and also I
would love to hear like which secrets
did you like secrets did you not like
which girls did you already know about
because that will help me like adapt
future talks as well so like if you if
you want to tell me like which ones you
knew and watch which ones you didn't
know I would love to hear that feedback
so thank you very much I hope you
enjoyed this
[Applause]